hallo ich bin alexander ich bin ruhig
und ich bin michael wir haben uns das
archiv der lebenden toten ausgedacht das
archiv der lebenden toten ein makabrer
titel
doch die drei theatermacher alexander
bauer romy weihrauch und michael nehme
cray wollen nicht provozieren sie wollen
dokumentieren wie geht es der
sogenannten core ohne risiko gruppe die
seit über einem jahr in isolierte
schatten dasein fristet dafür sammeln
sie digitale vermächtnisse von menschen
die sich von der pandemie bedroht fühlen
ja ich identifiziere mich mit der
risikogruppe weil ich diabetiker bin
seit 1994 und laut robert-koch-institut
gereicht dazu noch eine ganze bewährt
und wenn mir ist es so dass nicht nur
das herz selber mit betroffen ist
sondern dass ich auch in anderen körper
chrysler war wie zb die sogar menschen
mir ist nicht direkt betroffen ich bin
ich kann mich an dem risiko schützen nur
jammern ich bin erstens über 80 wert bei
180 m zum anderen ist bei mir
blasenkrebs diagnostiziert worden
und das ist doch jetzt gehandelt worden
dadurch bin ich natürlich super gruppe
die gefährdet ist
super gruppe nennt es ilse amberger aus
dresden
sie redet auch nicht von einem
vermächtnis sondern von erinnerungen
über 40 jahre lang stand sie auf der
bühne
seit der rente arbeitet sie als
freischaffende schauspielerin und
kabarettistin bis corona ihr leben lahm
legt als sie gefragt wird ob sie beim
archiv der lebenden toten mitmachen
wolle
zögert sie keine sekunde ich möchte
einfach dass der mensch ein bisschen
genauer guckt und sich bewusst wird dass
es leben endlich ist und sich auch
bewusst wird dass man sich nicht alles
nehmen kann und so eine situation ihr
macht es eigentlich sollte es eigentlich
für jeden deutlich machen
in meine die geschichte lehrt ständig
sie findet noch jene schüler
es sind einzelne schicksale wie das von
ilse die die theatermacher so
faszinieren
die drei wurden von der korona krise
ebenso hart getroffen wie die gesamte
kultur branche alle aufführungen wurden
abgesagt alle projekte liegen auf eis
auch privat hat die pandemie ihr leben
verändert
ich habe jetzt einen brief bekommen von
der bundesregierung dass sich
anscheinend zur risikogruppe gehöre was
mir vorher nicht bewusst wahr oder bzw
mir auch bewusst sein hätte können weil
ich schon seit meiner kindheit erstmal
habe ich habe jetzt auch mal angefangen
dieses vermächtnis zu erstellen und es
sind emotional sehr anstrengender
prozess weil das natürlich auch viel
darum geht mal dinge durch zu denken die
man sonst eigentlich wegschiebt trotz
allem ist es natürlich halt dann in dem
moment wo man diese fragen beantwortet
oder wo ich diese fragen beantworte ging
mir das natürlich schon nahe irgendwie
und habt ihr noch mal so konsequent
alles noch mal irgendwie durch gedacht
was da eigentlich mein umfeld betrifft
ja stadt wegen der korona krise den kopf
in den sand zu stecken haben die drei
theatermacher beschlossen aus der not
eine tugend zu machen
sie überlegten sich wie sie kreativ mit
der krise umgehen und die ängste der
betroffenen sichtbar machen können
[Musik]
ich arbeite schon seit vielen jahren
nebenbei auch im sozialen bereich als
persönlicher assistenz für menschen mit
körperlicher oder psychischer
behinderung und also dieser ich glaube
diese frage habe mich persönlich sowieso
immer umgetrieben dass diese menschen
oft nicht gehört werden dass man
vielleicht ein projekt macht um menschen
die möglichkeit zu geben
mediale repräsentation zu erfahren
die eben nicht vielleicht auch geübt
sind trend unbedingt die nicht die
besten sprecher sind die nicht
inszenierungs experten sind und trotzdem
was zu sagen haben ich glaube dass es
schon großes bedürfnis gibt sich zu
zeigen wenn man erst mal wenn man sich
erst mal traut diese hemmschwelle von
ich hinterlasse hier auch ein ein
digitales abbild von mir was auch
zugänglich ist ja für eine relativ große
öffentlichkeit also wenn man diesen
gedanken wenn man sich mit dem erst mal
anfreunden kann hatte ich schon den
eindruck dass viele teilnehmende ganz
klar diese sätze formulieren ich bin
nicht nur teil einer statistik sondern
ich bin ja auch ein mensch und ich
glaube für einen gegenseitigen dialog
auch gerade in so einer pandemischen
zeit ist es ist es schön dass doch viele
auch diese verantwortung aus den
risikogruppen wahrgenommen haben sich
nicht als opfer zu führen sondern auch
als akteur einer gesellschaft glaube ich
das archiv soll über die pandemie hinaus
erhalten bleiben
betroffene die else möchten zeigen
hinter dem abstrakten begriff
risikogruppe stecken echte menschen mit
echten geschichten und jede von ihnen
ist es wert erzählt zu werden
solange noch ein und ich denk biste noch
irgendwo vorhanden
[Musik]